20 years you've been married to this
woman
you're full of crap sir
let's go to robin who joins us in
lexington kentucky robin
how can we help hi um
i am right up to my ears sorry
um i've got barry the guy you talked to
out about an hour ago with his wife and
has been doing separate incomes okay
well i'm kind of in that way and my
husband's on disability
social security is not just ssi and two
children
so with the government with that i can't
work they won't let me work because
they'll take his check
so um i mean i've got student loans i've
got over
118 000 in student loans i've got a
master's degree
and we're finance company we're pawning
everything just to make by
it's what the 15th of the month and
we are broke what did you get your
master's
what did you get your master's degree in
and and for what purpose um
well i've got my master's degree in
ministry
um i was wanting to go to the mission
field but you know financially that's
not working out okay
which i know most missionaries start out
because i'm from a missionary family
start out with nothing anyway how much
is your husband's house
how much is your husband's disability
check what's that what's that income
the net coming in each month it is it is
7.98
793 okay
and my and the two kids are 7.93
so we have those will be fun within four
years
so we have three payments of 793 a month
coming in
that just started the raise in january
yes okay and that's the only income you
guys have coming in
be on the income okay
you know my house is paid off i paid
that with the first stimulus
i do not get the second student risk
because i didn't file in 19.
okay and so you have the student loan
debt of 118
000 what other debts do you all have um
well we've got
things that are all in pawn um we have
a finance company um
i have uh we have another finance
company which
you just like cash express i don't know
if you know about that
i sure do i do well i do that
so and we are
we are postponing like watermelon
electric bill we're just making payments
to keep it on
my water bill because of the leak was
over almost 300
this month so where if you guys are
bringing in right now around twenty four
hundred dollars where is it going
well i only have the two checks he only
pays the finance company
and i don't know what he does with his
money and the other two
i pay i make payments on everything else
okay so you guys are are operating
what's in uh
divided money yeah okay
okay how long have you all been married
robin
maybe 20 years next month okay is this
the way it's always been
no i we we started out working until
he he got sick and got cancer twice
and some health problems happened okay
all right well in looking at this i mean
how old are your kids
and the ones that are on disability or
we have three that are still well one
160 to get married
and she'll be 18 next month i've got a
14 and a 15 year old better
no deuces around disability okay well i
i can i can say this you know
the the one of the most important things
for you all to do
with limited income right now is to
absolutely be on a plan
and these finance companies i'm going to
tell you right now those things
are eating away and the charges and you
know
you got to get this cobweb off of you
and
you guys aren't going to be able to do
this working independently
you're going to have to sit down and
come together and that's talking about
putting your money in a joint account
together a bill paying account
and really starting to dig in and look
at this
this is i've tried that he just he just
doesn't want to do that
okay are you okay he's been married
before and it's
not that there's no trust or financial
needs just he won't do it
right well you guys been together 20
years okay so i i don't know
what happened in the previous time and
and and that ain't your fault
i'm going to tell you right now um and
so you know are you all plugged into a
church at all
yes i am um he is it now okay and we're
in a van small church
i'm really not in lexington i'm outside
the mexicans and i'm more close to
tennessee line
okay and you look at mccree county we're
the poorest in
the nation so i live in a very small hey
robin
robin i i i you know listen uh can i
shoot you
really really straight here and and i'm
gonna try to say this as lovingly as i
can
but you are you in some ways are victim
of really bad government policy and i
can't stand
when i hear calls like this that you
know if i go to work
he loses his disability and i don't know
what's going on with the kids
we don't really have time to break that
down but i think you're going to have to
also consider
how much money could you make if you
worked a full-time job
and what would you now i did have a job
about two years ago
okay how much were you bringing home
what was your net
um i was bringing home
a month okay that's that it's always i
worked at walmart so i was a full-time
employee at work
great but here's my point your full time
at walmart and if you had to for a
season
you could work a second job beyond that
and if you got that take home to 2 500
or 3 000 a month
you're coming out in the positive i'm
telling you you have
got to get back to full-time work and
this puts the pressure on the hubs to
kind of come together here and we go hey
look
we cannot keep taking disability
payments right and trying to live off of
that you cannot do this anymore robin
you got to go out and work your tail off
and when you do that this is america and
i'm sure in kentucky and tennessee
there's plenty of jobs you can get out
there and make a substantial
amount more than even if we lost those
disability payments and go
who cares but we're free from the
shackles because right now
you're limited i'm pretty fired up robin
robin you need to go get a job
and i mean like another job no no listen
i could go back to walmart they would
hire me back in heart because
i'm hanging up on you yeah right now
because you need to get in the car
and you need to go get a job and you
need to play this back for the husband
and hubs listen to me hubs
i'm shooting you straight hubs 20 years
you've been married to this woman
you're full of crap sir you don't have
trust problems you have discipline
problems
and you don't want to own up to it and
so you're leaning on a crutch from a
previous relationship
that was 20 years ago let it go bro
let it go and step up and i know you've
had health problems and i don't begrudge
you for that but you can still be a man
and own this problem with your wife
and take care of this take care of your
kids take care of them
and i got to tell you well you know what
because this is
this is wrong yeah no and it's a
systemic problem this is a systemic
problem it's a
government benefits problem where it
motivates and disincentivizes people
to be free but here's the other thing
this dude has no excuse
to not do joint bank accounts and sit
down with her and go i'm going to stop
spending my
benefits check however i please because
i'm so freaking miserable
that it's my excuse i'll tell you
something you better take over no you're
good dude because my blood cause
it's wrong it's it's wrong i see your
neck getting rid you're
i hope he watches it robin you better
play it back for him
cause i'll be the bad guy yeah all right
we got to help people
that was coaching yeah yeah there's the
kick in the pants ain't no pat on the
back